meantime leaders in Iran are promising a
tough responses of us abandons a nuclear
deal Elizabeth Palmer is in Tehran with
how one lawmaker said a u.s. withdrawal
could lead to global chaos Elizabeth
good morning good morning everybody in
Iran is waiting anxiously to hear
president Trump's remarks already the
currency has dived in value in
anticipation of aggressive moves from
the White House President rouhani the
moderate president of Iran has simply
said that if America moves that
undermine or pull out of the nuclear
deal then its own credibility is going
to suffer worldwide but it's the
Revolutionary Guards who have sounded
downright threatening they know they're
going to be targeted their head Mohammed
Jafar said that if there are new
sanctions against his organization then
the u.s. had better move its military
bases a thousand miles back from Iran's
borders in other words out of missile
range but the bottom line is that Iran
really needs foreign investment to
create jobs for its young educated
workforce and whatever the White House
says
is bound to drive that foreign
investment very far away and it's really
going to hurt charlie
this moment I ran Thank You Liz